did you miss your chance to become the
world's greatest detective on
PlayStation VR well you'll get a new
chance this month I'm Tony and this is
your virtual gamespot news update Batman
Arkham vr is no longer a PSV are
exclusive it's coming to the oculus rift
and HTC vive on April 25th Rocksteady
Sefton Hill commented on the port he
said the Dark Knight has always been an
incredible character to work with due to
his psychological depth so it's really
exciting to use this immersive medium to
delve deeper into his psyche than ever
before we're thrilled that pc players
can finally wear the cow for themselves
and take on the role of the world's
greatest detective with the addition of
the HTC vive and oculus rift versions
Batman Arkham vr will work with the
oculus touch and vibe controllers plus
the usual dualshock xbox one gamepad and
steam controllers and if you're looking
for more DC superhero action before
launch day why not visit our gamespot
universe channel
[Music]